[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour le dernier numéro du
7 8 aux robes de cette saison le
magazine européen de la rédaction de tv
78 qui a décidé de profiter de quelques
rayons de soleil et d'un peu de chaleur
pour poser ses caméras à l'extérieur et
plus précisément à la turbine
nous vous ferons découvrir cet espace
dédié à l'innovation et aux
entrepreneurs qui est ouvert il ya plus
de six mois à cergy pontoise
au total ce sont près de 6500 mètres
carrés d'espacés de bureaux et de lieux
de vie répartis sur trois sites qui
accueillent les entrepreneurs chercheurs
ou encore étudiants du territoire la
turbine qui bénéficient des fonds
structurels européens pour son
financement
nous rencontrerons son directeur
jean-claude céleste
lui aussi est entièrement consacré à
l'innovation et à l'aide des jeunes
entreprises
le ski cub nous aurons également
rendez-vous à l'incubateur situé à saint
quentin en yvelines heureux
bénéficiaires des fonds européens pour
accompagner les créateurs et repreneurs
d'entreprises à sky
nous ferons le bilan de trois ans
d'activité et notamment de ces derniers
mois marqués par la crise du coc vide 19
enfin nous ferons un rapide tour de
l'actualité européenne la plus récente
avec notamment une dernière session
plénière à bruxelles pour les
eurodéputés un conseil européen à 750
milliards d'euros entre les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens pour un
corps un nouveau vice président en
charge des affaires européennes à la
région ile de france
[Musique]
jean-claude célestin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le directeur de la turbine
merci de nous accueillir sur l'un des
sites de la turbine le site emblématique
ici ce nouvel espace qui est ouvert dans
l'agglomération de cergy-pontoise il y a
quelques mois
nous sommes ici donc sur le site le port
ils se nomment le port la turbine je le
disais en introduction c'est un espace
d'accompagnement pour toute la
communauté entrepreneuriale du
territoire l'objectif justement c'est de
créer vraiment une communauté qui se
rencontrent et qui peut travailler
ensemble sur sur chacun de leurs projets
l'objectif c'est de créer en fait un
écosystème avec des entrepreneurs que ce
soit des donc on a deux trois types de
contrats
incubé qui ont moins de deux ans
pépinière d'entreprises qui ont moins de
3 ans et hôtel d'entreprises au delà des
trois ans donc ils peuvent aller jusqu'à
6 7 8 ans et d'avoir ces entreprises à
différents niveaux de différents
secteurs d'activité et qu'ils puissent
travailler ensemble
cd s'entraider et nous les accompagner
au mieux ce qui veut dire que
potentiellement on peut suivre faire
toute sa vie d'entrepreneur ici du début
jusqu'à une certaine évolution de
plusieurs années tout à fait sûr que si
on part du principe aux autres en
première année d'accusation on peut
faire douze ans à la turbine la turbine
sa ouvert en décembre 2019 forcément
quelques semaines et quelques mois avant
le le coc vie de 19 et la crise
sanitaire qui a touché la france et qui
touche encore la france depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois pour vous ça a
été un faux départ
comment vous avez vécu cela et est-ce
que vous avez dû du coup arrêté des
projets qui étaient déjà en cours et
bien lancée alors oui forcément on a été
on a été impacté alors on a ouvert voilà
début 2020 exactement de vie 2020 le
temps que les travaux se terminent
on a ouvert avec un bon taux de
remplissage on a eu malheureusement donc
deux mois après obligation de fermer le
site puisqu'on a fermé le site pendant
deux mois
l'agglomération d'ailleurs à aider les
entreprises puisqu'elle a suspendu les
loyers pendant deux mois ça nous a
freinés dans l'élan mais je dirais que
c'est plutôt positif aujourd'hui sur la
sortie par rapport à ce que j'attendais
puisque on était à 56 % de taux
d'occupation avant la crise qu vide et
aujourd'hui donc on est à 66 %
donc là et d'entreprises qui était
rentré dans des comités avant la crise
qui ont quand même maintenu leur entrée
et il ya eu même des créations d'emplois
sur sur le pont pendant le coït
puisqu'on est passé de 197 emplois à la
fin du premier trimestre à 249 sur le
site sur la fin du deuxième trimestre on
a eu effectivement quand même trois
fermetures de sociétés des petites
sociétés plutôt avec un profil un qi
incubation qui démarrait qui était
vraiment qui commencé la
commercialisation et qui ont été freinés
dans leur élan est ce qu'à un lieu comme
ça se justifier encore plus après ces
mois très difficiles et cette crise qui
va peut-être se manifeste encore plus à
la rentrée
oui c'est notre rôle est encore plus
important ici est le rôle d'un psy de
coke comme celle ci c'est déjà de se
retrouver pas tout seul quand on revient
je trouvais qu avec une communauté avec
un écosystème de pouvoir par exemple
faire venir ici on a fait venir très
rapidement ici la dpi des banques sur
les différents prêts qui ont été mises
en place par l'état c'est d'abord donc
tout de suite pour eux le lien avec la
bpi et puis on a créé un accélérateur
qui s'appelait restart qui a été pendant
trois semaines on a fait travailler une
petite société sur la reprise comment
communiquer après la crise
comment reconquérir des clients voilà ça
avait duré trois semaines et les
entreprises sont montrés satisfaits
ça crée une dynamique en fait un
finalement et est effectivement comme
gullit a fait une crise comme ça notre
le rôle de la turbine est encore plus
plus important merci jean claude
célestin pour vos précisions
on va rencontrer maintenant justement un
entrepreneur qui va pouvoir nous
raconter son parcours ici aussi comment
lui il a vécu la crise ici à la turbine
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
docteur zaouani bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président fondateur des volina
le groupe santé alors je ne sais pas si
je les biens prononcer mais à peu près
on cible votre coeur de métier vous
porter un projet ici vous êtes incubés
depuis le début de la turbine depuis
janvier 2020 et vont porter un projet de
solutions nutritionnelles pour personnes
âgées est ce que vous pouvez nous nous
parler de votre projet avant qu'on parle
de votre présence ici à la turbine de
votre projet à vous je m'intéresse à une
problématique qui touche maintenant un
français sur quatre qui et l'alzheimer
donc de plus de 65 ans et à notre
problème qu'il a dû nutrition et donc
après exactement mon dernier brevet mon
troisième brevet qui est maintenant dans
18 pays qui était vendu à 55 millions
j'étais un cube est un star l'abc
maintenant à la turbine pour créer ma
propre emploi et démarrer cette nouvelle
société
donc cette société il commercialise un
concept c'est pas seulement un produit
un concept ce qui est une triade nutri
cognitive ou la personne en le prend de
façon holistique avec une solution
nutritionnelle sous contrôle médical qui
est un brevet que j'ai inventé où j'ai
découvert que chaque personnage et du
nutri il ouvre la porte à une démence
donc l'objectif de cette solution dans
un cadre holistique c'est de prévenir
exactement et de prendre en charge les
personnes âgées en stade précoce de leur
démence c'est à dire c'est essayer
d'allonger la durée d'arrivée de la
démence et de l'alzheimer racontez-nous
quels sont les avantages d'être la
turbine pour vous j'imagine que c'est un
cadre de travail efficace assez calmes
mais aussi l'opportunité de rencontrer
du monde d'échanger d'avoir des moments
de devis vous savez je travaille sur le
sujet âgé l'un des problèmes sujet c'est
les allemands quand on est sortis
directement quand on perd notre travail
quand on perd exactement comme un virage
on se trouve dans l' isolement
les coachings exact le code système de
coaching le système d'accompagnement
n'est pas adapté à des cadres
exactement qu'ils étaient des
responsables comme j'étais qui gérait
des équipes
donc il faut trouver des chasseurs de
têtes mon ami chasseur de têtes c'était
pas possible de me trouver un poste
quand je suis arrivé à la turbie j'ai
trouvé une famille j'ai trouvé un
encadrement
j'ai trouvé un coaching exactement je
savais pas que ça veut dire entreprendre
je sais pas comment gérer comment monter
un business plan
comment faire de la communication toutes
ces choses là c'est là où je les a pris
merci beaucoup docteur zaouani c'est moi
qui vous remercie bonne chance à vous
pour la suite puisque vont entrer dans
une phase très importante pour vous je
rappelle que vous êtes le président
fondateur d'evry n'a eu le groupe santé
merci beaucoup on va se rendre désormais
dans un autre lieu de ce type à saint
quentin en yvelines on change de
département le skill cube accompagne les
créateurs d'entreprise depuis 2010 est
le lieu a été lui aussi financé en
partie par les fonds structurels
européens
non
du val d'oise aux yvelines de la turbine
au ski cub nous sommes donc ici présent
désormais au ski cube ce lieu qui
accueille depuis plus de trois ans deux
jeunes entrepreneurs de chercheurs et
des repreneurs d'entreprises ou encore
étudiants qui cherchent à s'implanter à
développer leur projet et leur start up
nous avons rencontré à ce propos jean
luc berho l'un des responsables du lieu
et qui bénéficient des fonds européens
on a eu des aides d'abord pour
l'ouverture du bâtiment
son réaménagement puisque nous avons
ouvert ce site dans une logique
d'accompagnement des entreprises toutes
activités confondues n'avait qu'un focus
force sur l'incubation d'entreprises et
l'accompagnement des start-up donc des
aides pour la partie à dire immobilière
de ce projet et ensuite d'autres types
d'actes ont été déclinées plutôt pour
l'accompagnement les entreprises des
start up ou les porteurs de projets de
manière plus classique parents nous
accompagnons globalement une vingtaine
de start up
toutes activités confondues puisque
l'incubateur que nous proposons
l'incubation que nous proposons ici dans
le cadre le stick hull est un incubateur
généraliste qui prend appui sur un
prestataire privé qui est à cuba nuances
mais c'est un incubateur généraliste
donc nous avons en moyenne par an une
vingtaine de start-up que nous
accueillons nous hébergeons et que nous
accompagnons pas sur des sujets donc
qu'ils peuvent être les sujets du
digital
loisirs au sport une grosse panoplie de
services qui font aujourd'hui la
richesse des ski-clubs légitimité vos
aventures en raison puisque ça
sous-entend en amont que nous avons eu
un accord donc une forme de validation
et de reconnaissance de la part des
instances européennes et de la région
puisque le conseil régional est
fortement partie prenante dans ce
dispositif
donc pour nous effectivement c'est une
c'est un crédit supplémentaire et et ça
nous permet de valoriser notre haine
notre accompagnement au delà du
territoire du 50 ans du bim et nous
rayonnons je lui dans l'écosystème
on va dire de paris saclay d'une manière
générale mais plus largement aussi en
ile-de-france la crise économique
malheureusement celui-là la crise
sanitaire donc de grosses difficultés à
venir pour une bon nombre d'entreprises
ceci étant l'ensemble des
institutionnels et des acteurs
économiques ont mis en place un certain
nombre de dispositifs notamment des
dispositifs financiers
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et fortement aussi appliqué
dans la relance économique avec un plan
qu'il était décidé il ya quelques
semaines maintenant par les élus donc
une forte mobilisation financière dans
un premier temps on va aussi accompagner
un nombre important d'entreprises
donc ça devrait aussi permettre à des
entreprises qui pourraient être
confrontés à ses difficultés économiques
de pouvoir peut-être passer ce cap de
manière un peu plus 10 pour être plus
précis nous évoquer le sujet des
start-ups était on va dire la bonne
surprise à la sortie du confinement
nous avons eu tout au long de ces trois
mois des contacts quotidiens avec la
quasi totalité d'entre elles et
finalement ils ont réussi à passer
d'autres en noir
d'abord avec le moral et c'est important
quand on est dirigeant d'entreprise
parce que ça permet aussi de garder de
lui
de motiver les collaborateurs et les
associe donc un moral d'aplomb pour ces
start peur et puis les perspectives
d'activité qui se dessine qui n'ont pas
été complètement coupée et qui se
dessine de manière positive on l'espère
on va dire pour les pour les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois on poursuit
7,8 europe avec un rapide tour de
l'actualité européenne en brèves avec
notamment la nomination d'un nouveau
vice président pour les affaires
européennes à la région ile-de-france la
réunion les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens pour tenter de
trouver un accord sur un plan de relance
continental de 750 milliards d'euros
il aura fallu cinq jours et quatre nuits
pour trouver un accord les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement européens sont
finalement parvenus à s'entendre sur un
plan de relance post que vit 19 le 21
juillet dernier
ce plan de 750 milliards d'euros inédit
par son ampleur prévoit notamment un
remboursement mutualisés pour plus de la
moitié des sommes empruntées qualifiée
d'historique par les chefs d'état ce
plan a aussi été critiquée
mathilde andrew et eurodéputé
responsable dans les yvelines du
rassemblement national estime notamment
qu'il hypothèque l'avenir et entraîne
une perte de souveraineté
les parlementaires européens qui se sont
retrouvés à bruxelles le 23 juillet pour
une session extraordinaire le temps de
débattre de l'accord négocié par les
chefs d'état s'ils ont salué le plan de
relance ils ont manifesté en revanche
leurs craintes quant à la baisse prévue
du budget de l'union européenne pour les
sept prochaines années
un nouvel élu pour les affaires
européennes à la région ile-de-france
othman nasro récupère le portefeuille
détenu jusque là par stéphanie von euw
de l'élu des yvelines devrait occuper ce
poste jusqu'aux prochaines élections
régionales prévues en mars prochain
la région ile-de-france qui répond aux
questions des bénéficiaires des fonds
structurels européens dans le cas de la
crise liée aux kovy 19 une page mise à
jour sur son site internet répond aux
nombreuses questions soulevées par les
porteurs de projets franciliens
[Musique]
elle risque d'accident embouteillage au
péage stress et aussi des enfants
parfois très impatient prendre la route
alors des vacances peut-être eu une
véritable épreuve à l'heure du
chassé-croisé quels sont les
comportements de nos voisins européens
respecte-t-il plus les règles que nous
sur la route
éléments de réponse avec olivier génois
ex responsable du centre d'information
europe direct à saint germain en laye
concernant la sécurité routière la
moyenne européenne est de alors 49 décès
par million d'habitants en france la
moyenne est de 53 décès par million
d'habitants le pays qui fait le mieux en
termes de sécurité routière et la suède
avec 25 décès par million d'habitants le
pays qui fait le moins bien et la
roumanie avec 98 décès par million
d'habitants chaque nationalité à ses
mauvaises habitudes en matière de
conduite on se rend compte par exemple
que
les français ont une légère tendance à
ne pas vouloir mettre les clignotants et
aussi s'énerver assez rapidement au
volant si on prend les meilleurs en
terme de sécurité routière donc les
suédois on se rend compte que eux ont
une fâcheuse tendance à ne pas vouloir
respecter leurs propres limitations de
vitesse dont qu'ils ont toujours une
degré ils ont toujours tendance à rouler
un peu plus vite que ce qui est prévu
les espagnols au volant eux ont
l'habitude de klaxonner un peu trop
souvent d'autres comportements qui
peuvent être plus ou moins délicat on a
par exemple les grecs qui eux ont eu
tendance à oublier d'attacher leur
ceinture de sécurité enfin les polonais
préfère descendre de voiture pour
s'expliquer avec les autres
automobilistes
c'est la fin de ce set hui d'europe le
dernier de cette saison si particulière
je vous souhaite évidemment un très bel
été à tous en france ou ailleurs en
europe
vous pouvez retrouver l'ensemble des
modules et reportages de cette émission
sur notre site tv 78 points comme et nos
réseaux sociaux quant à nous on se
retrouve dès la rentrée prochaine pour
un nouveau pour une nouvelle saison du
7-8 europe à très vite sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]